oh
[Musique]
en
en potager c'est le règne de la
géométrie donc vous voyez les v les
allées bien tracé qui délimitent des
grands rectangles de gazon et dans ces
rectangles en fait on a installé
d'autres alors d'autres formes
géométriques a pas que des rectangles
vous voyez là-bas ya des triangles et à
des losanges enfin vous verrez de
l'autre côté aussi à plusieurs autres
formes et ses carrés en fait sont
cultivées avec des légumes et pour une
vraie consommation donc c'est pas
purement décoratif mais en revanche on
attache beaucoup d'importance à mélanger
des légumes avec des fleurs donc on a un
potager fleuri
et alors chaque année en fait ça sera
différent parce que d'abord on peut pas
planter les mêmes légumes au même
endroit deux ans de suite donc en fait
on fait en hiver un plan de culture en
reprenant les plans précédents de telle
manière à s'assurer d'une bonne
alternance
on suit les principes aussi
d'associations et légumes certains celle
d'autres ne s'aiment pas donc il faut
faire il faut respecter un petit peu
tout ça et puis on répartit tout les
pieds de tomates puisque à peu près 200
pieds de tomates sont plantés donc il
faut les répartir un petit peu partout
et chaque année en fait ben allal
ludovic a été assez créatif sur les
tutos rage donc là c'est la première
fois qu'on fait qu'on fait qu'on fait
avec ça avec ces grands bambou et puis
peut-être que l'année prochaine ce sera
encore différent c'est pas grave on
laisse courir un peu alliés libre cours
à l'imagination
[Musique]
quand on achète des plantes en fête
après c'est l'idée qu'on va aller on va
les assemblées en fait quelque part on
va les disposer et puis on va faire en
sorte qu'il y ait quelque part il ya
comme un tableau qui secret mais c'est
un tableau avec beaucoup de dimension
dimension au cours des saisons dimension
avec les fleurs et on a vu les écorces
tout à l'air déjà mais mais aussi les
feuillages et en fait si on avait des
feuillages tous du même vers ce serait
je pense assez ennuyeux donc en fait on
va jouer nous aussi beaucoup sur la
balle hors la forme des feuillages mais
aussi leurs couleurs donc là il ya un
bel exemple de panachage poudre et c'est
un dodge ya à côté on va voir un
feuillage plutôt rouge ça c'est un
berbère hills et puis on a des
feuillages presque jaune ou vert jaune
on en verra encore des plus jaune ça une
autre sorte berbériste d'ailleurs
[Musique]
jardin doit se découvrir il doit pas se
se s'imposer à nous se révéler d'un seul
coup d'accord il faut qu'il ménage sur
surprise faut que ce soit une
déambulation avec découverte au fur et à
mesure qu'on va se promener pour créer
des émotions des centres d'intérêt et c
est toujours comme j'étais dans le
potager avec de l'internet toute l'année
donc on s'est beaucoup inspiré
d'ailleurs au départ du jardin du vaste
et rival de la princesse torah à
varengeville
[Musique]